okay I genuinely can't get upset when
other people feel the way that they do
about my appearance whether they think
I'm a one or a 10 because beauty is in
the eye of the beholder I like I mean
it's like facial symmetry so I actually
like agree with what he gave you like I
would probably give you seven eight
because your face is very symmetrical
okay and I bet like you probably had a
modeling contract at some point I I was
a freelance model I haven't yeah that's
what I'm saying because like I write
people eight to ten and you could get a
model I don't really give seven so I
think like if you could I don't I try
not to because I like it's based on
someone else came up with this but like
I just thought it made sense like eight
to ten is like you could make money off
your looks five six you can't that's why
I don't give myself above a set like
above a six that's why I say five six
because I feel like I'm more pretty cute